thank you okay so I guess I supposed to
talk about information theoretic view of
you know the communication complexity
that we are talking about in this
workshop so I wasn't sure exactly what I
should talk about so what I figured what
I'll do is take all the titles of the
talks all this and then see see what the
talks are about and then talk about
whatever comes out ok so these these are
the titles 06 you can see I just took
out the times and and the names of the
speakers and so on so let's see what we
get you'll see in a second assuming it
works
let's see if I like it can you see
that's what
ok ok I think I like it so I think what
what do we have here I think we have
information complexity and that's one
clear topic that we have in this
workshop I think we have interactive
communication it's another click clear
topic and I think we have a motorized
communication if you want we can run it
again maybe we'll look even better but I
think we can see three topics coming out
so we have information complexity they
came came out here and an interactive
communication and amortized
communication I think it's pretty good
so maybe we can talk about these three
topics so that's what this website does
ok and if you want to know how how I
thought about this I got this idea from
tongue not on a phone Ted course so i
can tell you later how ok so all right
let's see so all right ok so we're going
to talk about these three topics
interactive communication amortize
communication and commit and information
complexity and we'll get an information
perspective of these topics and I think
now looking at the sizes that things
came up then maybe interactive
communication should be first and
information complexity second and
amortize complete communication was a
little smaller so let's keep it us right
ok so um so first interactive
communication so there were a lot of
lots of talks about interactive
communication and I won't tell you about
the information theory version of
interactive communication that's
actually that's what it's called and
it's been there for many many years so
ok
issues
right um okay so talking about that and
all right so um so first let's very
briefly talk about what we're going to
do so we know that when a sender conveys
information to a receiver one great way
communication suffice as if I if I have
something to tell you then I can just
talk to you like on the TV they just
talk to you and that's sufficient they
want to tell you the news they don't
need any feedback from them however if
the receiver has related information
then interaction can help and so what we
want to do now is want to explore that
and unlike the interactive communication
that we heard about this week in this
interactive communication there are no
transmission errors so everything I say
you here precisely everything you say I
here precisely okay so what we're going
to do is we're going to look at some
examples we'll see the role of
interaction will see us always will out
look at the number of bits that you need
to achieve a goal and get some
theoretical bounds and some open
problems and of course this will be
highly compressed because I have 30
minutes for free talks so so here is the
first example so and I should say that
unlike the results that we have heard
most of the talks we've heard this week
brand new these talks are very old
they're like this is like maybe 20 years
old and some of them will seem maybe
somewhat all but also may be somewhat
new I suppose so ok so imagine so that
the end teams in the NBA and two teams
playing in the game and typically the
results are announced I'll go to the
radio said there was a match between the
Celtics and the Lakers and was won by
the Lakers I don't even know if these
teams still exist ok so now so this is
what a typical nodes and I was saying
now imagine that one day you hold your
radio and you hear that there was a
match between the Celtics and the lakers
and then they grab your radio and I hear
that it was won by the Lakers so as a
result you know the two teams
played you know this the celtics play
the lakers lakers but you don't know who
won I know who won I know that the
lakers want but I don't know who they
played against and now you want to know
who the winner is why because this was
your radio nice solid so you want to
know who the winner is so you want to
know who the winner is which of those
these two teams and I don't need to know
who they played against cases that
clears the information just need to go
for me to you so the question is how
many bits you must transmit can ask on
the average or twist and he will talk
about the worst the worst case so
basically the situation is this you know
two teams that played I know one of them
and you want to know which one I ok so
the only thing I would say is this that
I don't know the index so it's not that
I know that I have the first or the
second you know celtics and lakers i
know one of them i don't know if it's
the first team on the second team so
here so there is an informant and
recipient like the whole like everything
in this stuff I'm the informant I want
to tell you something you want to hear I
know the winger you know the game I
don't need to know anything you want to
know the winner so the question is how
many bits we not must commit we need to
communicate in the worst case and so
first let's look at one message because
I don't need to know anything i can just
transmitted to you I know the winner I
don't need to know who lost I actually
don't know I don't want to know any of
these things this is just for them I
thought or something though he's going
to talk about debate or something so on
so um so l11 will stand for the single
message so that one is number of bits
you need in the worst case okay and so
clearly l1 is less than Logan because we
can just we know can order there in
teams and I can just tell you who
without using the fact that we know a
lot of information so l1 is less than
log n the question is whether we can do
any better okay if we had one more
minute then they would have let you
answer it but since we're really pressed
with time I'll just let you know so if
you have any one ways protocol like in
this case you're looking at that one the
winner determines my message because all
I know is who won so what I transmit is
a function of of the winner so here the
team's the end of them and here is what
i transmit imagine that there are two
teams in this case the lakers in the
Pistons for which I trust me the same
message the message imagine that this is
my protocol this is bad because if they
happen to play each other I'll
transmitted 0 and 1 in both cases you
cannot transmit back so you will not
know who won so therefore if we have if
you have a one-way protocol we want it
to be correct every team has to have a
different message has to be the case and
therefore you have our if if two teams
have the same message then there's an
error if there is two teams play so all
messages must be texting so must be any
different messages so at least one of
them will have at length login so
therefore if we insist off on a single
message no more way communication we
need to transmit login bit so the
question of course is where the
interaction can help and notice that I
don't need to learn anything I only want
to transmit to you so it's not clear
that you should be transmitting to me
that's the question can you tell so two
messages you transmit first remember you
know the two teams and then I will fly
so how can we do it again with one
minute you would have solved it but with
zero minutes I'll tell you so we order
the teams from 0 to n minus 1 and these
are the binary representation you know
so this is a location one up two up to
four in this case one up your game you
know two teams that played all right
assuming this so what you're going to do
is you're going to tell me the team's is
the plate so you know to the two teams
the plate they have different binary
representation there must be a location
where they differ so you tell me the
location where they differ and then they
tell you in that location
has something so for example in our case
you know the lakers and the Celtics
there are two different sequences there
must be different in at least one
location in this case they actually
differ into it choose the first one
location to and tell me the tube the two
teams different location to and I tell
you I know that the lakers won so I know
that they have one so I tell you they
have one in that location and that's
efficient way to distinguish so how many
bits did we so it works and how many
bits did we use you you transmitted and
one of the coordinates they'll log the
end team so they log in coordinates to
describe one winner is logo again and
then I respond with one bit so we saw
that with two messages we went to from
log in to log log in logarithmic and
another interesting thing is that even
though you didn't want to tell me
anything you actually transmitted
essentially a whole bit so the question
is can we do better can we go beyond
that either with two messages with any
number of messages so what is this so
this is a special case of a general
problem what is the general pop the two
communicators calling for mint px and py
and each of them has a random input x
and y and both know the underlying
distribution they use an agreed-upon
protocol and you allow them to exchange
em messages or are around everyone and
LMK is the number of bits that both must
transmitted in the worst case so
accounting bits going in both ways we're
not cheating and we're looking at the
worst case so l1 is the number of bits
you need with a single message l 2 with
two messages and so forth clearly these
numbers are not increasing because you
can just have empty messages so ah the
minimum is going to be some some
non-negative so they'll be going to be
to minimum we call it le infinity and
this number because we're looking in the
worst case we will not care about the
distribution except what will care about
is the supported because the
probabilities don't matter just what is
possible what
not as we're looking at the worst case
yes it's determined by the support set
which others the set of all x and y's
they have positive positive probability
we okay so far so fast forwarding to the
results what can you say what can you
say about this so you can show that on
the maximum improvement that you can
achieve by interaction is that most
logarithmic so the if with one message
you need l1 with any number of messages
you need at least the log of that in
fact at least this much and why is that
because if you can do something very
with interaction you can always simulate
it by a one-way protocol by just
imagining what the other person would
respond so it's exponential so so this
by this is sufficient to solve the leak
problem because we saw that we had a
protocol with two messages that required
at least log log n plus one but two
messages is bigger than l infinity and
infinity by this is at least log l plus
1 in la esposa and log in l1 was was log
in to get log log n plus 1 all of these
must hold with equality okay so that
means that one message can be
exponentially wasteful so for example
the leak case l 1 is to 2 delhi infinity
minus 1 this was logging this was Logan
6 financially you require if you insist
on a single message you require
exponentially more bit you might require
that exists there's some problems for
which the sister hey however and one of
the interesting results here says that
two messages are almost an optimum if
you are allowed to messages you are
almost always at most four times away
from the optimal so there's no there is
no pointer jumping or pointer chasing or
any pointers stuff that you can be
arbitrarily off after two messages so
your thing a factor for for all these
parts all communication poems
you can also show the two messages are
not optimal there are problems such that
with two messages you're twice away from
from the best and you can also show that
for most spots bias means they're not
too many the support set the support
that is not too dense most spouse
distribution the recipient actually must
transmit most of the bait will counter
intuitive just like in the league
problem the person who the person who
wants to say something transmits few
bits the person wants to hear sighs most
of it so what are the open problems here
so first question is how large can L to
be so we just said that L 2 is always
four times an infinity can be twice can
this gap be closed 11 and then maybe
more interesting question is whether
there's a fixed number m-maybe for three
or four messages such that a messages
are asymptotically optimal for any
problem so yes when you write general
distributions you've been talking about
worst case so what do you mean there do
you um no that's a very good question
because I'm right after this slide I'm
going to go to non general distributions
but you will not see that so yeah so
this this these are these are questions
that apply for all distributions next
slide i'm going to start talk about like
distance distributions they have more
structure just this is support sir
second please distribution is just it
supports right because we are correct
because we're asking about worst case
then the only thing you care about is
the supported the if you asked about the
expected number of bits you'd care about
the actual this mission absolutely so
yeah yeah everything here is a theorem
everything no it's not a fault even
though you folk theorem it's a few what
do you mean by for any problem so if you
give me any s any set s you come up with
any scenario that you have in mind this
is X this is y these are the possible
connections between these are the
possible x and y's that are possible
whatever you can do with any number of
messages with two messages you can do it
most four at most four times you can
view avenue you can do it off from
either as a graph or as a subset of d
kotian product that's the more natural
way but it's also you can view it as a
graphical time so is so I can't get why
how do you do point you're jumping into
messages no no no this is not okay so i
think i have a slide that relates this
to communication complexity this is not
a general communication complexity
because this is not a general function
here f of x and y is x I just want to
communicate you my value so pointer
jumping the function is more complicated
than that so in I have a slide about
this but in in communication complexity
the the set of possible input is trivial
every x and y are possible the
interesting powers come from function
here it's the opposite the function is
trivial f of X and Y is X the
interesting part comes from their
supporter I know an edge and you know
one of the vertices and you need to tell
me that all this I would like to think
of it as a Cartesian product you know
the row and I know a column but not
everyone corner possible so that has a
direct maybe you have very very slight
shock because each one knows one vertex
and they will there's a graph and each
person knows the input is an edge each
person knows wine water text and the
other I'm not sure I'm not sure that
it's exactly the same because if you if
you said hyper edge yes if you're
talking hyper edge yes but if you're
talking edges so for graphics not always
the case maybe I have let me see I think
I have something that okay just one
second ok so here so here's the
difference between this and
communication complexity then we'll
we'll answer both of you ok so
communication complexity I don't need to
tell it anyone here but you have x and y
everything is possible and the
interesting part comes from efes we said
ok and you ask how many we need to be
exchanged everything is the same it's
just that everything is possible but
what is an effing side and here you know
this is the this is at least as of like
many years ago they the pointer jumping
chasing problem so you can they could be
an exponential gap between any m and n
plus 1 in this case it's a different
problem so this was defined with a bus
el gamal many many years ago and you
have x and y and it's some subset that
we both know of possible of possible
values so if you want to look at it as a
graph like I think you guys are looking
then um what you what happens is that
you can look at these as the vertices of
the graph and these are the hyper edges
so I know hyper edge and I know that
you're in one of the vertices so you
need to say hi program yeah if you want
bipartite then you could do that but
then it's not one has a vertex and the
other one has an age both of them as the
vertex and are connected so there are
three ways revalued ways of coolant with
us ok ok so here we're talking effects
and wise is just too evil ex and we can
see that in this case two messages are
simpler to play often
so so now I want to go to the non
general case like a subset of these
pumps correlated files so this this
whole problem is motivated by the
following somewhat special case which is
you have two people and it showed them
has a file included files are closely
correlated okay why maybe the successive
image frame so you transmit images one
after the other the receiver has the
previous image you have the new image
and you want to communicate only one so
there to the what a receiver and what
the sender has are closely related or
you have your downloaded previous
version of of Yosemite and now you want
to download the new one the two files of
somewhat related or during the cloud you
have distributed database and the files
are fairly similar going to defecation
you want to synchronize them okay so in
all those cases to cooperate in order to
convey the file you asked how many bits
you must transmits a special case of
this one so in some sense that they will
not describe but it's fairly accurate it
suffices to consider the following
simple problem so imagine so if m which
is finding one way protocol for
insertion so what is the pawn so imagine
that each of us has roughly n bits and
our team in insertions and NT are known
in advance so this the receiver knows a
sequence of length and why and the
sender knows a sequence of length n plus
T because it was derived from YT
insertions and the two sequences such
that X can be obtained from Y by T
insertions for example ne6 and TS to the
receiver has this six bit sequence and
the sender has a sequence of length 8
which is obtained by two insertions in
this case 0 here in one here if you can
solve this problem one way you can solve
essentially a good chunk of the
communication box just by solving this
particular problem so the question is
how many bits must this sender
transmitted in order to convey it
value so why are we looking at
insertions on so the two the two
possible answers to this first is the
more interesting one maybe why is this
sufficient for almost everything but I'm
not going to talk about that I just want
to tell you i'm looking at insertions as
supposed to insert one and delete one or
two big something so if this is the
sequence Y order that they receive that
the receiver has of length let's in this
case of length free if you look at it
the number of sub sequences that it can
that the sender can have if you delete
one bit it depends on the sequence that
you start with if you start with the all
0 sequence they could only be only one
sequence if you start with 0 1 0 then
the sender can have three different
sequences by deleting one so we don't
like that if you look at in at
insertions then it doesn't matter what
the receiver has receiver is why the
center will have the same number of
messages this is what if you believe
that statement then it's easy to see
that it's just look at the all 0 then
how many will help you can have the all
0 sequence and then inserting one so
it's going to be in general it's going
to be n plus 1 plus plus 1 and respond
to zero percent of scrunches one which
is imposed to in this case file okay so
so there is a benchmark if the sender
remember the center knows the sequence
knew what the receiver has if they knew
then they would just need to enumerate
all these and Sam the smallest one the
second smallest up to the largest they
need to transmit log of n plus 2 bits
agree so they would know what what this
person has they would just pretend I him
they'll create all possible super
sequences the account i have the first
the largest or mexico graphic the second
Hodges the store so they would need
exactly log of n plus to see me exactly
but in our problem they don't know the
sender does not know what the receiver
has and the question is can we approach
this benchmark this this ideal number
that you could get if you knew what the
receiver has and the answer is that for
one insertion you can't so maybe we
don't have time to go over this
is this clock erectors someone just move
it up below ok ok so for one you can you
get exactly what you need and the open
question is um what can you do for two
insertions I can just tell you that what
what is what is easy to show is that for
to insertion you need between two log n
which is what you need if you knew what
the other person has and twice as much
is easy to show a little less difficult
to show is that if you allow three
messages then you can get to the right
number three message three messages
going once and returning once you can
get to the right number up to a
logarithmic additive number and the
question is whether there's one way
protocol that achieves say the upper
bound or so second topic information
complexity I'll pretend I didn't see so
maybe we can skip on over a lot of stuff
here because we heard a lot about it so
in brief so communication complexity
problem is beautiful but is very complex
there is I can look at worst-case
expected case randomized so on it's
messy but there's a nice concept that
relates all these things and it's the
information complexity of the function f
that was described by a paper by a meet
here and she and with and the NDL and
what it is it's defined in the words of
a lot it's creature which consists of
mutual informations and minimize overall
conditional mystery of informations
minimize of all protocols any the nice
things about it is that it's additive if
you take the function raise it look at
multiple copies it just multiplies and
it lower bounds or communication measure
is that you not it's in particular it
also lower bounds the amortized
communication complexity which is just
your pick up the function many times and
you ask how many bits do you need /
instance and so there's been a lot of
works about these two problems and about
what four years ago so bravoman and rao
show that in fact not only the
information complexity not doesn't just
lower bound the amortized complexity but
in fact it's equal to that so so i just
want to tell you about the information
theoretic view of this so so in
information theory there's also been
working about on this and and the same
roughly ninety five so celebrating 20
years so the same the same definition of
the information complexity was defined
in this particular case for a given
number front so the information
complexity for one round two round and
so on and for the same reasons and and
the the same results were derived so
this is for two rounds so it was shown
that if you look at the amortized
communication complexity with one round
or two rounds it's the same as the
information complexity for one moment
and there were in fact these results are
limos a little stronger because the
upper bound so the the indic if I'm not
mistaken you guys can tell me in the
communication in in the computer science
literature the upper bounds are for bit
error correct like you the error for
every bit is less than Epsilon
start with AC is it but here in
information theory you can actually get
block diminishing blocking or so it's
not just that every bit will have
probability one percent of being one can
have that the whole block no matter how
big it is will have probability of one
percent or then to the minus for being
one and in fact most of the work in the
proof is is is proving this part and the
lower bound is also for average error
rather than probit which is also
stronger just edit it that if you want
the average error to be small then you
need that many bits and so they were
extensions are these results were for
one and two but it also exchanged
extensions for any any number of rounds
and so on and just want to mention a
couple of things that you get from
looking at in the information so I'm
trying to advocate looking at the
information theory literature a little
bit and also may be gaining something
for some intuition and some and seeing
what's out there so um so a couple of
things that you get from looking at the
information theoretic our view is that
you get diminishing blocking or
probability which at least in we view
this as the called sort of the gold
standards because you have a laptop with
terabytes of data you don't want one
percent of the bits to be wrong you want
hoping to be correct you can also get a
communication region namely not just the
sum of the number of bits but you can
get like any which pairs are possible
the sender's one person's transmitted so
much one percent receiving so much this
whole thing falls in the in the realm of
rate distortion and once you get to rate
distortion it's actually like a whole
world so you cannot just look at errors
like what people have looked before but
you can look at any you can define what
the error means like you can say that if
if the value of that set a function
takes 10 values and they value the
actual value is 6 in your new goes 5
that's a small error but if you go to 4
it's a large error so you can just look
at the Sun any any measure between the
actual value and the and the value that
you're estimating
you can get a 404 yes so you know the
finishing block air the amortized
communication complexity equals the
information could place it but not for
these not for these but for the for the
for the original one just the error you
say is there an error is no canary ok I
can tell you for sure that you can do
one into because I was involved in those
results the results the extension is
actually seems fairly pleased for
something so okay so these are the
extensions now going ishwar in MA okay
they showed the same thing for every are
when you look at the formula it's not
that surprising that it will generalize
and they also looked at what happens in
the infinite case like I think you guys
looked at I'm not 100% sure that they're
looking at the block but or at least for
at least four fixed number of rounds I
they should be able to but in the
infinite number of fronts on much are
they also had so both both we and they
this was just a tool for us we were
trying to get like some nice formulas
that if you give me a function there is
a nice phone mesle for example for us we
related it to related it to the graph
entropy should be right in here
someplace conditional graph entropy so
so for one way it's conditional graph
entropy and they have and they have a
method for the general case which they
call alternating concave occasion or
something where they don't just want to
look at this phone but they want to tell
you what what the answer should look
like but I don't know if those are for
the block here for hours is the whole
block
so yeah so so once you have this you can
look at any any kind of measure that you
have between the correct value and the
incorrect value and the x and y you can
you can have a formula for that and also
once you get to on rate distortion it's
all this thing is a question of
minimizing mutual information and
there's a formula there's an algorithm
called the el remoto Blair with
algorithm so you can actually this
actually even like a matlab routine that
you can plug in so it's not exactly for
this pump but but you can probably adopt
this algorithm and get something they
will approximate what you want because
it's it's just maintenance for this
problem you have right distortion palm
it's a mutual information you want to
minimize it just like in this case and
it's a way to solve it you do it
iteratively because you have x and y and
you iteratively go between exactly I
think okay so there's the third topic
which I can tell you if you want a job
yes so this is very similar to slip ian
wolf on my nerves is this connection
clearly worked out yeah definitely um so
the case so on the case where f were f
of X so maybe if we go back to the
previous case f of x and y was x that is
the slippery move case but here it's a
function that you want to learn so it's
more complicated in then select remove
by it's related to whiners if and and
many of the results you get from that
it's not quite here is exactly this
regular book right though though L equal
to one case is identical to slip involve
but L equal to two case almost seems
like you need an auxiliary random
variables or something more than just ok
talking about so you're talking about f
of X f of X is X perfect X I so what we
saw is that if you have a single
instance you need to interact like in
the league palm you need to enjoy if you
took this instance and repeated it many
times independently like what everyone
is doing when they talk about
interactive communication they have x
and y some distribution will
many many times in depending if you do
that you in the slap in wolf realm and
then you know that h of x and y is the
minimum that you need to get you that
you can get by with and sloping wall
full they will give it you so if you
repeat it many time there is no need for
interaction in the one case yes but just
repeat twice you but if you if you take
your problem you duplicated many times
independently you will not want to do
too